all right folks episode number 125 with
the one and only john perkins economic
hitman
uh john when was the last time we
interviewed was a year ago year and a
half ago when we sat down i think it was
before you had us another baby it was
before i had another baby yes before
brooke before brooklyn and i think i
think it was it seems to me it might
have been in august yeah of
yeah it was prior to
he was right he was right yeah he said
there's no way trump's gonna win
prognosticator he was he was but uh
you know it's so weird the timing of
when you're here today because this was
not planned like there is no conspiracy
going on today it happens to be that mr
john perkins the economic hitman
is sitting here
right after the durham investigations
came out which i'm sure you haven't read
or followed though you don't know what's
going on there no idea which is great
which we'll talk about because you have
no idea if you watch mainstream media
you wouldn't have you wouldn't have an
idea because everybody i bet they had a
conference call and they said the key
word to use in your title is allegedly
allegedly everybody was about allegedly
but we'll get into that for some people
that don't know what uh your background
is let me just read the wikipedia so
people know what the wikipedia says john
perkins
is an american author he's best known
for his book confessions of an economic
hitman 2004 which was a big hit
in which perkins claims he had played a
role in an alleged process of economic
colonization of third world countries on
behalf of what he portrays as a cabal of
corporations banks in united states of
america the books claims were met with
skepticism and rebuttal by some but he
spent
more than 70 weeks on new york times
bestseller list has been published in at
least 32 different languages and is used
in many colleges in university programs
that's a pretty good intro right there
by wikipedia because typically they talk
but they're being nice to you yeah
except
they're saying these things are alleged
allegedly and they get the numbers all
wrong it's way more than 32
languages now is it in farsi is it at
least in farsi i'm pretty sure it is it
has to be on pharmacy because you you
know you got some your choice words
about the show over there so so for
folks who don't know for folks who have
no idea what it is i mean
i've i've interviewed hitmen before like
legit hitmen okay who their job is to
they come they kill you that's their job
that's what we call the jackals that's
okay you call them the jackals okay
but you know i was
you know adam is always looking for
great jobs
and this morning he went on uh what was
it what what was the job
all these things he was looking at how
he can apply to be an economic hit man
he couldn't find a single job i looked
everywhere
he looked everywhere
how does one become an economic hit man
well
i guess the
the first question would be
why would you want to
because i don't recommend it
for me how it happened was that
when i was
graduating just about to graduate from
business school
i was going to be drafted
and i really didn't want to go to
vietnam i didn't really want to kill
vietnamese people or be killed by them
so i was looking for a way out and i was
married at the time to a woman whose
father was very high up in the
department of the navy and his best
friend was very high up in the national
security agency which was draft
deferable
and they arranged for an interview so i
go in for this interview
spent a couple of days on on a lie
detector and i was sure i failed
for one thing when i had been in
middlebury college i i uh
there was an incident with an iranian if
you can believe that be careful with
those guys
well the truth truthfully this guy
carried a knife i mean a little tiny
jackknife but he showed me how
he put his his thumb way up the blades
with just a little bit of it touching
he'd already showed me this he'd been a
professional soccer player the club of
rome in in in in in italy and then gone
and then gone to middlebury college and
we i was in uh
we were in a bar together and and uh
what year is this uh 64.
okay
and uh
anyways make a long story short a big
heavy farmer sucker punched me knocked
me across the room and for hard my my
friend from iran comes up and slashes
him across the cheek
lots of blood comes out he's got this
little tiny it's just a pin perk really
but it looks bad feels bad and the farm
is screaming his head off and for hard
pushes me into the men's room and out
the window into otta creek this river
that runs by and we make our way back to
the dorm at middlebury
and the next and i was pretty drunk the
next morning there's a knock on the door
and there's the cops so they pulled me
into the police station
as i'm sitting there waiting to be
interviewed
another one's escorting for heart out
they don't let me talk to them they put
put take me in and they start
questioning me did you see ferrard with
the knife and i lied i just lied and
lied and like i feared for hard more
than i feared the police questions
i too fear iranians more than i feel
yeah well
i've always been told don't sit too
close to them you know i think this is
good actually
i'm worried about him not me yeah i get
this between i got a knife in my left
hand right now
anyway you know so now i'm taking this
this nsa
lie detector test and they asked me if
you ever had a have you ever been
interviewed how to run in with the
police
and i had to tell them yeah i lied to
the police so i figure well this is this
is going to screw me and then they ask
me how i feel about vietnam i say well i
i don't i don't intend to go and so i
figured i failed miserably got it but no
they hired me and you know
oh they offered me a job
and you know the the truth of the matter
is
they were very happy that i had the guts
to
to lie to the police
plus
fahard's father was a general in the
shah's
military
and worked for the cia
so here i was friends with a guy whose
father was in the cia and iran
that was good material and they knew
that they'd already lost the war in
vietnam basically it wasn't public
knowledge really it was a lot of
controversy but the nsa knew so they
didn't care that i didn't want to go
they were pretty smart of me not to want
to go there so it was really funny so
you know i get i get to offer this job
and then i end up going in the peace
corps for three years because they
encourage that to learn another language
to learn survival techniques et cetera
et cetera and afterwards i came out and
was hired and they told me
you know when you end up working for us
you may not actually work for us you may
work for a private corporation
but they have connections with us which
was true so i became an economist chief
economist at this consulting firm that
had very very close ties to
the united states uh
what are we going to call it
intelligence community
information gathering spy agencies did
you know at that time like are you aware
what's going on
no not really i mean
you know it's so easy to convince
yourself that you're not aware even
though i had suspicions but
uh i came from a poor pretty poor
teachers family in new hampshire i grew
up in a boys boarding school surrounded
by rich kids and my dad was a teacher
and he didn't make any money
the school gave us a house and food we
we had a decent life didn't want for
anything
but i was surrounded by kids who came
from tehran and paris and buenos aires
and park avenue in new york
and
you know i heard all these stories and i
was stuck in this little town in new
hampshire always
and so did these kids bully you or did
you have good friendships with them i
had good friends friendships i was
pretty i was i've always been a good con
artist that's what it takes to be an
economic hitman you know
but
and i was captain of two sports teams
and so on oh yeah so
but but i always had this inkling to go
to tehran to go to paris to go to these
and suddenly now as i get into this
business i'm flying first class around
the world i'm meeting with presidents
i'm doing all the things that i dreamed
of doing so i really didn't want to know
the truth even though when i was the
more and more i began to suspect it but
the line that i was sold patrick was
that what you're doing is a really good
thing
because what i was what i was paid to do
was to convince countries that had
resources our corporations covet like
oil to take huge loans from the world
bank or one of the sister organizations
and hire our companies to build big
infrastructure projects like power
plants and roads and airports in these
countries which would make our
our companies get big profits
the rich families in the country would
prosper because
they own the industries they own banks
they own the things that benefited from
improved infrastructure but the majority
of the people would suffer because money
was diverted
from education health care and other
social services to pay off the debts on
the loan
and in the end they couldn't pay the
debt so we'd go back in and say hey
you owe us
so sell your oil or whatever copper
whatever the resource was
real cheap to our corporations without
environmental social regulations
and
that was really
you know what my job was but
statistically you could show that when
you invest in these
um
infrastructure projects the economy
grows it does
because we measure gdp or gnp
growth
and that really just measures the very
rich
so so let's let's go let's go back to
you know what i recall from our meeting
there
so
the business model of what you did so
one if i remember
that you didn't directly work for the
government because if you did get caught
then it would look like it's the
government so it was a corporation that
you would work for
uh and and that corporation is who would
send you to go negotiate on behalf of
the us government
with not necessarily the bigger
countries it was more smaller uh not
even midsize you would just say with
smaller countries that you would go to
that had some kind of a natural resource
that america wanted and then the
negotiation was we're going to come and
build some infrastructure we'll invest
some money into your country they'll go
into a ton of debt
then in a way to get money back is
you're going to allow us to build a
military in your country you're going to
give us these resources for 50 cents on
a dollar or 10 cents on a dollar pretty
much for nothing and then if you don't
listen to us we're going to kill you is
that pretty much
explain the business model you follow it
yes and yes it is and
so we're going to kill you part was i i
wasn't going to kill them i never
carried a gun but i knew the guys were
right behind me we called them jackals
they were cias you were talking about
hitmen earlier they'd be in the room
with you while you're having this
conversation no they'd no uh
i suppose i theoretically didn't know
anything about them but who's in the
room with you when you're having these
coverage are you the point man or you're
saying hey here's the deal yeah and
who's with you
i'm probably just meeting one-on-one
with the minister of finance or perhaps
the president you're rolling in solo to
these countries
and having these well no i've got two or
three of the guys who work for me okay
outside they're probably not sitting in
the meeting they might be it they just
depended but but they were there to help
produce the numbers i i was frankly i
was a lousy economist
i was chief economist but i was a good i
was a good talker like i said i was a
good con artist but i knew how to hire
the guys that could crunch the numbers
and come up with these econometric
models that showed how much the country
was going to benefit
that was used to convince the presidents
and they would use it to convince their
people the press in their countries and
so on
you know there was an interesting
cartoon that sort of sums this up
that came up
many years ago and it showed me or an
economic hitman
in one hand
holding a fistful of dollars
and saying hey mr president in this hand
i've got a hundred hundreds of millions
of dollars for you and your family if
you buy my deal and then in this hand i
got a gun in case you don't
and that was pretty much it i didn't
have the gun but i knew that there and
he knew because the united states you
know we've admitted to taking out and
and ending
the life of salvador hyundai of of chile
uh the shah of iran
uh and most a decade in iran before that
most of the deck particularly
and we didn't really take out the shot
we took out most of the deck lumumba in
the congo zm in vietnam albans and
guatemala and recently 2009 in honduras
president zelaya
so a lot of the activity was in
central america south america and then
in the middle east is that or africa
or the majority of the countries
anywhere any country that had resources
our corporations coveted that needed
money also well it didn't sound like
iran that didn't really need the money
but we but they needed us to protect
them from russia
and and saudi arabia you know had they
had their reasons but usually it was
countries that needed money had
resources
i focused a lot on latin america because
i'd been there a lot i speak fluent
spanish so it was a it was a it was a
natural for me but i also spent probably
during ten years a year in iran
uh a lot of time in indonesia
now let me ask you john why why did this
these prime like omar torijos i believe
right panama why did which was one of
your favorite guys that you would meet
with why did some of these guys
agree to sit down with you what is the
call for them to say yeah i'll sit down
with john what call came before you
showed up
they would usually get a call from the
world bank maybe the secretary of state
of the united states somebody's saying
you know this is this this man's passing
through your country and would like to
arrange a meeting to you and talk about
what we might do to help your country
that's the script that's the script
something like that yes and that phone
call is made to who to to the president
or to his chief of staff or whoever sets
up such meetings but it would probably
end up in his hands and to rehost
so he was an interesting guy you know
panama i was a very charismatic party
animal loved to you know loved his
cigars and his and his rum and
barbecues you know i got to know him
very well because he was very
charismatic that way very flamboyant or
not flamboyant just pardoned flamboyance
this is in the 70s yes this is before
noriega and everything that happened
with that yes
right yeah norway came after that so
this is during the negotiations for the
panama canal tree you got it and it was
it was carter and and torrijos
and you know torijo's got pretty much
what he wanted in that
and he became a hero throughout the
third what we call the third i like to
call it the
the the the lower income countries if
you want to call it that
um
he became a hero and so he became very
dangerous so the united states really
wanted to bring him under control so i
was sent down to reign him in
and he wouldn't be reined in uh he was
he had tremendous integrity
and a big ear
also you know he liked to be on the
front page and and he liked to be known
as as david facing goliath you know his
little country underdog mentality total
you know very very small country very
small population but it had the canal
and and he became very very well known
throughout the world as a guy who would
stand up
so when you spoke to him and you you use
the same protocol that you use with you
know
others in the past
it wasn't effective with this guy when
you spoke to him he just wasn't going to
budge and he openly would tell you what
did he tell you openly when you guys
spoke
well he was the one that really helped
me understand what we were truly doing
he pointed out to me something and i'll
use today's numbers
but he in those days it was similar he
today if three
three americans own as much wealth as
half the united states population right
and if those three americans made ten
percent on their assets last year and
and half the country lost three percent
and everybody else stayed the same we'd
show a growth of something close to four
percent
so it looked like the whole country
prospered when in fact only three people
prospered half stayed the same and half
lost three percent
and torii has pointed that out to me and
so if that's true in the united states
with three people and as much as 50
imagine what it's like where three
people own not as much as 95 which is
true in a lot of these countries
torrijos pointed out to me said you know
these numbers that you're throwing
around like gdp it's totally rigged in
favor of the rich
you're not helping the poor people with
any of these countries
uh and so he he was one of the people
that really helped me have to face the
truth of what i was doing and at the
same time you know one time he took me
out on this yacht he didn't he didn't
own the yacht but he had a lot of
friends he was always out on these
yachts you know we're on this yacht
we're drinking uh
all kinds of you know rum drinks and
disease we're surrounded by these
beautiful bikini-clad ladies uh sounds
horrible just awful you would have hated
it yeah yeah
you know i just seen you ladies yeah
it's horrible patrick i just saw a video
of you on a boat as you were arriving
here in florida deciding to come here it
was kind of like that except you were
surrounded by all these guys
don't get me started on that john
okay so you're you're having this drink
with him you're on the
having a conversation with him what's he
telling he has to be on the back he
offers me a cigar he says hey john why
don't you come work for me
you won't make nearly as much money but
you'll have a lot more fun and you'll
feel really good about what you're doing
for the world
he tried to recruit you
good for him yeah it was pretty
convincing yeah
i didn't i wish i you know i know i
don't wish i had any you know he
i think he got assassinated he's you
know it's never been proven but his
plane went down very his private plane
in a very uh suspicious under various
assistance what was it it was called
what was the thing called it was a name
for it you know like the
project something that uh uh united
fruit or was that more guatemalan no
that was more guatemalan
with our benz yeah yeah so with him
you know you said something about when
he got on the plane
right after the whole deal he did with
carter there was a tape recorder that
went in and the tape recorder blew up
has that been verified that was a tape
recorder or no no
when he got on the when he got on the
plane
uh somebody handed him a tape recorder
and uh that's the suspicion is that it
was a bomb but you know
when a plane blows up there's no smoking
gun because it blows up too and just
three months before less than three
months before that jaime roaldos the
president of ecuador who also stood up
to me did not accept the deals he i did
i wasn't as friendly with him he was
loved by the way he was loved and adored
he wasn't like he was loved and
authority and democratically elected
yeah for the first democratic elected
president in ecuador in a number of
years
uh he wasn't as as as warm and fuzzy and
friendly as as torijo so i never got to
know him personally the way i did terry
house
but so he he died in this plane crash
uh in may
and uh in 1981 and uh tori has met with
his family after that and he said you
know
my brother jaime was just assassinated
by the cia
and again that was never proven but
there was a suspicion
and they said you know i'll probably
probably be next but don't worry because
i've signed the panama canal treaty with
carter so i've accomplished what i
really came here to accomplish and less
than three months later exactly almost
the same thing happened to him is what
happened to roll those now you don't
know if so for example you go meet with
somebody and you come back and they
don't do what you ask them to do you
make the phone call back to the
corporation you were working with and
you say this is a no-go
and the individuals you called who were
they was it just simply your direct
supervisor were you talking to the ceo
of that company who was your
communication with well my direct
supervisor was a senior vice president
who became president so i was talking to
the top management of my company and the
call sounded like what hey bob they said
no he's not willing to budge yeah i i
yeah i mean i would usually try to couch
in terms of a little bit more color to
look it
me look a little better you know like
hey i just spent the last month
miserably drinking rum drinks you know
and smoking cigars and hanging out with
bikini-clad women and
and still i failed that kind of thing
but yeah basically that was it and then
so dave but but you didn't know the
business model like it's not like they
told you the business models if they say
no we're gonna go take a guy out you
don't know that you just or was that a
almost like code red
in the marines you know the movie a few
good man where everybody knows it's a
code but it's not written anywhere but
it's talked about amongst leader was it
kind of like that yeah i think it was
like that i knew
but i didn't know how many people that
you met with right after you left they
got killed who didn't do a deal was it
those two guys yeah everybody else did
the deal everybody else at the deal
everybody else i met with the deal so
but you never sat with shot you just
partied with joe you spent some time
with the shop
yeah did you do a deal with the shower
no yeah we did deals with the shah but
the shah nah so that was a different
situation so the shot didn't need to
take out loans because he had money he
had money just he just needed to give
our oil companies permission to go in
and take his oil got it and that's what
we were working on and and you know the
shah was was very clever and then he
sort of pitted russia again the soviet
union against us he said well you know
if you guys don't build me
these cities if you don't help me build
russia is going to do it russia is going
to do it so we were building huge
transmission lines that went all the way
from
uh kirman down to bandar abbas we were
building the big military we actually
were building the military base at
bandur abbas which now is is a thorn in
our side you know it's it's it's
controlling the straits of hormuz
but we were building it basically as an
american military base it was an iranian
military base but where america would
have a big presence
and uh you know using the shah's oil
to pay our companies to make big profits
building this military base what would
you know were you was there ever
the concern of
during that time it would be the 70s
right when you're waiting having
dealings with shah right
what did you know about the consortium
agreement of 1954 because that was the
biggest uh challenge that four countries
had yeah they were not happy about the
amount of power he was getting because
he was going to give everybody it was a
25-year agreement they signed
from 54 and it was coming up in 79
and i think the pm of france
britain i want to say
germany and carter obviously met in
south or central america to talk about
this guy's getting a little bit too
powerful and we got to do something
about getting rid of this guy
were you involved in the exodus of the
show or no no okay no in fact
um the night before the bombs went off
in what was it shiraz or israel
um i was in the hotel intercontinental
in iran in iran and in tehran at the bar
and he had a tap on the shoulder and
it's for heart
i haven't seen him since then since the
night even though i saw him after the
nice same guy that father is a general
that that would come through
yes and fahad says to me um
we have a little bit of a chat very very
brief and he says i've got an airplane
ticket for you tomorrow and air france
that five o'clock in the morning or
something to fly to rome with me and i
said no no i've got a meeting with the
ministry of finance tomorrow was very
important he said no no you're coming
with me and i said i came out look at
this me he said and he looked at me in
the eye he said you're coming with me or
you may never come out of this country.
so i was on that and he said my father's
living in rome i said your father he's
the shah's general what's he doing in
rome he said he's no longer the shah's
general he resigned
he's in rome we're going to go stay with
him
and i left the next morning and then the
next that next day
is when the beginning of the end for the
shah began why were you in iran was this
77 or 78 this is 78 17 78 79 it can't be
78 78 just before the 79 revolution how
long were you and i round four
well i i was never there for more than a
month at a time but probably close to a
year over 10 years
so i would i had an office in tehran i
had an office in iran i had one in
panama you said you said 10 years you
were he was there no like in a month out
of town but a year over a span of 10
years wow yeah so what was iran like in
the 70s basically i loved it i loved it
it was beautiful you know and i traveled
all over from the caspian
down to the streets of hormuz and i went
down in the desert from kiermann and it
was just beautiful and tehran was
incredible and it was it was so
progressive you know you could sit out
on what was called pallavi avenue at
that time named after the shah
these cafes
and the iranian women were i mean the
miniskirts and on palo vie avenue were
shorter than in paris if you can believe
that and it was really it was really
struck by how wow how how impacted all
that must have been when the when the
moonless took over you know and all that
that change it was shocking because it
was so there was no sharia law going on
right there they're not in the full garb
nothing was going on no no no no
wasn't for that so it was like it was
like the paris of the middle east at
that point you know for her the shah's
uh the princess
you know she was a model of of beauty
and sexuality well sensuality
excuse me not openly you're getting
choked up talking about her i get it
john
yeah and you know she sponsored this
major tennis tournament where they hit
all the
biggest stars from the world come and
play tennis and an international film
festival
by the way the top three countries in
tourism in the 70s you ready yeah burma
cuba iran
and it's crazy how those countries yeah
have completely
done a 180 yeah now frank sinatra would
go perform there all the time zahidi was
dating elizabeth taylor
iran was like the place rich people went
to like about where rich people go to
today we're going to go to dubai
way before there was dubai it was tehran
iran you'd go then you'd go to bandar
pahlavi which is a different port of
pallavi by caspian sea which you would
have caviar as if it's just regular you
have a coffee so then
the the the mullahs or whoever was
basically saying all right this is
enough's enough here yeah
what was that you if you were there for
10 years you must have you probably
don't speak the language but you must
have
sensed some
unease like okay this is the like what
pat is basically describing is the paris
of the middle east and that's where rich
people are going but there must be this
undercurrent of people not digging this
vibe
clearly did you sense any of that what
was that situation like that's what's
shocking is no i didn't sense it i don't
know that anybody sensed it i've become
friends since then with bob baer you may
know him the cia guy that the movie
syrian is based on he was he was deep
undercover spoke farsi as well as arabic
i don't think he was even i mean i i
don't get how
how difficult it was for us to
understand what's going on i understand
for me
that all the information i got came from
translators who worked for the shah you
know and they've all been tr they've all
been scared so they're sweeping things
under the rug everything's fine look
this way don't worry have a drink have
some fun i you know i would ask to
interview some of the poor people and
and so on and so forth but i always had
a translator because they didn't speak
english and i don't know what was
translated correctly and you know i know
that the same is true around the world
you get a lot of misinformation if you
don't speak the language you know i find
one of the reasons latin america was so
enlightening for me in torrijo's because
i spoke spanish right but in iran no i
there was we had no english iran was the
only country
uh at the time even it was saudi arabia
well a contract in saudi arabia was
actually with the u.s treasury
department to build stuff in saudi
arabia that's another story but i think
iran was the only country from where my
company
did not require
advanced payment for the work that we
did we trusted iran to pay its debts to
add the money yeah and when as a result
we lost millions of dollars when the
shah went down because they owed us a
lot of money which we never collected
because we took we totally trusted them
so it is shocking to me how
how little we understood has has any
country
taken a bigger 180 than iran because
what he's basically saying venezuela
would be in the top five because
venezuela used to be
a modern-day iran you're talking about a
country that has the most supply of oil
oil natural resources of course and it
was a beautiful place to go to next to
colombia a great place iran and they
also have beautiful women they also know
how to party they also know how to put
it together they also know how to you
know have fun
and iran did so as well but iran but but
venezuela i wouldn't put them on on the
same
iran iran is working on nuclear missiles
yeah but during the time during that
time
this guy
had a deal originally british petroleum
right was in iran bp prior to that it
was called the anglo something something
you know persian oil company you know so
it was a britain had a chokehold on iran
and they pretty much ran everything in
iran until mossader which was somebody
that you know his
uh i don't know if you dealt with
mosaddegh's issue i think other people
from the deck was the early 50s
you were still a kid yeah
was a guy most other would have been the
modern-day bernie sanders he was a
socialist and he wanted to take oil
money from iran and give it to everybody
and he didn't like the fact that the
rich people were getting richer and all
this stuff and he came in
and he he kind of wanted to negotiate
stuff with oil but he wasn't strong
enough to negotiate
and then zahidi which you know you know
his ideas uh
he was the ambassador of u.s zahadi was
a very powerful man
um and jose also yeah i would say that
as well but zahidi was how would you
describe zahidi he was
he like he dated elizabeth taylor zahidi
was like
a young zahidi
tyler spells this right
there's a z there's an h there it might
be a lowercase q it's zero it's not
tyler
can you get this right
hundred bucks if you spell this right on
the first 100 bucks i'll give you a
thousand bucks but
a r d e he went to a porn side
a r d s h i r
and then put z a h e d
okay
uh young okay go to images go to images
and this guy was like
the right to click on that one that one
right there is fine he's a guy in the
top left maybe that's a bad picture for
him but every look who is on the right
do you see what is on the right beetle i
can't really see who is that on the
right is that barbra streisand i think
that's barbara streisand
yeah zahidi uh uh it's crazy what's the
date on that article washington post can
you click on it flamboyant iranian
ambassador okay
died uh at 93 what age is that can you
get that get rid of that no that's so
you can i'll go back and see when he
just died because it has to be in the
last 18 months and this was who was he
in iran
he is he's the guy you go through if you
want to do any dealings with the shot so
this guy comes in
he creates uh a campaign together he's
like the chief of staff basically let me
tell you this guy is the shot cup he is
he's a very important guy got it he gets
rid of musa in a way i mean a lot of
people say he got rid of mossader but
can he see when he died i want to know
when he died it has to be in the last 18
months he gets rid of mozart oh really
shaw comes in i was supposed to
interview him he was sick when i was
supposed to interview him see when he
died i was supposed to e i think he was
living in switzerland or sweden
something like that november 18th of
last year that's
look at his birthday you know he's a
special guest october 16 two days apart
he died four months three months ago i
know he just died i'm telling you i had
a schedule go to switzerland
we got on a call with the guy he sent me
an autograph of his book saying i'm
looking forward to the interview because
we were going to have some interesting
conversations together but unfortunately
he died well do you see who his wife was
his first what his wife stood up until
1964. shanna's
yeah you know who that is well paula v
is pretty well known
yeah and you know he's he's lucky
because jovada who was prime minister
and and i got to know quite well uh was
executed he was he was shot by we don't
know whether it was a firing squad or
whether somebody shot him just before
he's surprised he lived islam yeah
that's what i'm saying he he's lucky he
made it because jovaita
right after the revolution was put on
trial and found guilty of all kinds of
things no question about it this
khomeini was after this guy for a
longest time everybody was like this
guy's not gonna make it no he's but he
made it to 93 legit respect for him to
make it that long by the way this guy
was the encyclopedia of everything that
took place during that time if there's
if there's a guy that knew it was this
guy anyways so the shah all of a sudden
went from being a 21 year old kid that
takes over iran
at 21 years old think about this
and his dad was a very uh uh feared man
very much of a dictator strong strong
dictator
shah was a little bit more gentle he
spoke seven languages
okay he spoke french he spoke
you know english he spoke better english
than you and i speak english if you ever
see him in interviews you'll be blown
away by this guy
so he changes everything in iran he
makes it but he says we got to get rid
of the
what do you call it the the burkas
berkeley you got to get rid of this you
got to make it a little bit more free
and then
some of the more conservative muslims
were upset because he was thinking women
are getting a little too loose too
comfortable with the way they're doing
they're getting too much power he
increased the age of women getting
married from 8
to 13 to 15. and i'm telling you that's
the number from eight a 55-year-old man
prior to him could marry an
eight-year-old girl
and he raised it to 13 then to 15.
and i think now it's back down to 13 or
some number like that in iran so he made
a lot of positive things but he became a
little too powerful and that scared the
crap out of us and britain and france
and germany because they could no longer
control them
and when he became too powerful that's
when they said we got to figure out a
way to hurt this guy and next thing you
know guys like him
maybe not him but guys like him showed
up and they
totally ruined iran because if it wasn't
for
economic hit men like you johnny it's
all your fault you understand this this
is the whole reason why i got you here
today that's why i wrote a confession
because i know it's true and
incidentally you know
the one country who left out of all that
was china so so ho ho veda was was
really flirting with china at the time
and using that in in the united states
his face
throwing it in our face you know not
only the soviet union yeah but also
we're seeing china's on the on on the
march here and the united states didn't
even realize that china was doing what
it was doing in the 70s what year is
this yes in the 70s and and so uh
you know the shah and and all of his
team
were
really really
sharp as they were shrewd they were
really shrewd playing the soviets
against the chinese the chinese against
the americans the americans against
everybody and the french were in there
in the english and everybody wanted a
part of iran and as is because of the
oil
because of because of the oil but also
the location so iran protects europe
from russia from from the soviet union
basically strategic alliance right
everything and and also
the feeling was that if the shah could
be was sick would be successful then the
rest of the middle east would probably
use him as a model which we liked
because he was a guy who who as patrick
said was very strong dictator
uh
but he also who was a strong dictator
the father the father was yeah yeah but
brutal i mean the son feared him
yes well and i think you referred to the
shah as a dictator and when you guys had
a speed run you used that terminology to
describe the shot did you not yeah the
shah was a dictator also as as patrick
said he was milder than his father i've
heard that
i've heard i've heard that i've heard
it's called misinformation
don't let this man fool you
but why so you disagree with what he's
saying
okay let's define a dictator what's a
dictator
well somebody doesn't have to be elected
basically not let's go maybe autocratic
well you could he was an imperialist
which i agree yes yes imperialist is
different than a dictator there's a big
difference what is the difference what
is the difference what is it so what is
britain oh it's a standard shape it's a
different standoff what did you say
you just say i gotta get my bag
would
would you say britain's form of
government is a dictator
no why not
because it's a parliamentary um it's a
parliamentary republic what does it do
you're saying you're saying that when it
was a you're saying you're you're you're
saying a monarchy is a dictator so it is
the definition no no no no no no no
certainly not not not in britain it
isn't because the monarchy doesn't have
control but in but in iran the monarchy
was ruled so but a dictator is what a
dictator says if you don't do what i
tell you i kill you
right
if you don't do what i tell you i'm
going to ruin your something yeah
something's going to happen okay i mean
you do you tell me in america right now
if god forbid you know joe rogan says
something they disagree with we're going
to ruin your life it's just a different
way of being a hitman yeah but in fact
that the shah did say that he said what
he ruined people's lives if they didn't
agree with him it it was a at that time
what do you call a cia at that time
what did you guys do then you're a
dictator i'm sorry so the way were we
were supporting a dictator no well you
are the ultimate dictator so if we
define them as a dictator you are the
ultimate dictator we tried to be yeah
that's what i'm saying we're trying we
have to be very careful when we drop the
name dicta because then that means fdr
is a dictator patrick i love the way you
talk about the important use of words
i've i've watched an incredible video
where you get into i don't speak english
it's my fifth language i'm trying to get
better at this thing
and i i love it can we pull up the
actual definition of a dictator
picture right next to it is going to be
but go ahead so you called the shot
dictator well you're saying that the
show was not a dictator no if
we have to define what a dictator is a
dictator is a political leader who
possesses absolute power dictatorships
of state ruled by one dictator by small
clique
the ward originated as a title of a
roman dictator elected by the roman
senate to rule the republic of emergency
but you said that in times of father the
father of the shah was a dictator but
the brutal dictator let me tell you the
father was let me like
the son never saw the father like this
father never played with the son it's
like you're lucky to be around your dad
you have to go learn and maybe once a
month or once a year would see his dad
the dad was feared brutal killer
my way or the highway and everybody he
got into he got exiled i think once or
twice
they kicked him out once or twice well
as and ultimately the shot took kicked
him out i mean it wasn't it was a cia
that came in and brought in the shot but
yeah the shot kind of replaced mostly
replaced most of the deck yeah but most
of that had replaced the father true so
yeah
i mean listen here's
iran had a true democracy
that was the bernie sanders of iran
that's who you're saying what that was
a socialist is who he was but he was
elected by the people yes he was elected
by the people but he was a socialist who
there is a no way he had the strong
personality of a bernie sanders that was
not him mossad was you know how he died
he died living in a small village by
himself chilling nobody bothered him for
years true socialist true socialism but
basically he was in the house arrest he
was but there's that little component he
had he had no choice
but he had capitalism in a socialist
community first of all first of all when
you you're talking about a guy you judge
a country by the progress and the
results that they're making what happens
if a guy doesn't get results you can
talk about a parent all you want
until you see the kids end up becoming
leaders you can call belichick a
dictator until they win six
championships you can call tom brady as
a quarterback a dictator because he's
you know often you know he's such a nice
guy
and then you talk to his opponents and
pittsburgh steelers and they're like
dude you guys don't know the brady we
know this is a dirty guy this is a
competitor this is a psycho guy right so
okay but he wins he got results so
iran under the shah made a lot of
progress that's all i'm saying the
progress was made under him
make the point you were making when he
asked the question
what was the question
you asked the question about the fact
that you know what happened uh uh during
and you were talking about the uh uh ho
ho ho ho veda and what he went through
and you know at the time because by the
way do you know what happened at the end
do you know why they killed him
do you know the cause for why they
killed him
well he was found guilty for what do you
know what he was found guilty for no you
ready craziest thing he was found guilty
he was tried
by the new established revolutionary
court under khomeini
for waging war against
god
oh yeah that whole thing that's right
that's right yes waging war against god
waging what can you imagine if that's a
provable charge right very approval
charge and they executed this guy at 60
years old i think he was 60 maybe like
60 or 70 years old yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think it's just very interesting
because i'm an american i'm jewish quite
frankly and i you know i look at things
from more of
middle eastern relations a lot of times
from israeli perspective
um
but i just think it's very important
because obviously pat born in iran we
cover you know iranian topics uh what's
going on there
everything they're doing nuclear you
know everything with that i just think
it's very important to to point out how
different iran was at one point and how
quickly under certain regimes things can
change
right it's yeah it's almost night and
day what you're describing of the the
rich places or people coming all over
the world the elizabeth taylors are
hanging out there the sinatra is
performing and now it's like
pat can't even go visit the country if
you wanted to
that's how different iran is and i just
think that's important to
to highlight it's yeah well if i go i'm
definitely taking the two of you for
sure
well i don't know
[Laughter]
i'll go anywhere in the world with you
except iran
are there are there anything not that
crazy are there any countries you are
literally not allowed to go at this
point of your career
uh
well i don't think i would be welcome in
iran okay at all i don't know whether
i'd be allowed to go there or not but i
probably wouldn't be allowed to leave
that's perhaps more important john
perkins let me ask you another question
you you know we've sat down with um i'm
not allowed to go to north korea well
nobody really was
encouraged to go there but we've sat
down with
you know mafiosos you know pat has done
uber amount of interviews with uh
the
names of names of names we all know that
and i i i'm always wondering like do
these guys fear for their life what kind
of retribution who what
what person out there is the son of
someone that they killed they come back
do you fear for your life at all is i
mean you're an economic hit man you've a
self-described con man who has literally
sat down with presidents prime ministers
dictators
some of them haven't made it out of the
much longer out of the meeting so where
do you stand on fear
i i don't mean to put you down but you
obviously didn't read the new
confessions that economically which was
published in 2016 where i talked about i
was poisoned
and lost uh percent of my large
intestine to a hospital in new york city
i was supposed to speak at the united
nations on a tuesday
on a tuesday i flew up to new york from
florida where i lived at the time
uh on monday
had lunch with this journalist who it
turns out probably was not a journalist
and that night i lost a little huge
amount of blood in my body was rushed to
linux hill hospital where eventually
they took out 70 of my large intestine
and a lot of the evidence points toward
poison it was never once again never
concluded because by the time we even
suspected it the part of my intestine
had been removed had been incinerated
which they do immediately as they when
they pull something out of your hospital
but
my life was threatened so when i started
writing the book after i was an economic
hitman i started writing a book about my
experiences
and immediately got anonymous phone
calls threatening my life and my infant
daughter's life and you can imagine pat
even if you've got an
internet child
and
at the same time i was taken out to
dinner by the president of stone and
webster a big consulting firm in boston
and been a competitor of my companies
that i just left
and he takes me out to dinner he says
hey you know you've got a great resume
you were chief economist one of our
competitors you had 50 people working
for you we'd like to use your resume and
our proposals uh you don't have to you
want to do any work for us but just let
us use your resume and i'm prepared to
write a check to you tomorrow for five
hundred thousand dollars half a million
dollars this is in the late 80s it was
worth more than it is today there's
millions of this more yeah and uh he
said then he says just don't write the
book
so in fact i'm getting the same
treatment that i've been giving these
presidents i'm being offered
you know i'm now without a job yeah i'm
paying profit half a million dollars
in one hand on the other hand
yeah and uh so do you deserve that
treatment though
well does anybody deserve that kind of
treatment i'm asking you i i live a
pretty moral life i don't i don't fear
for my life but
a lot of the stuff you're doing kind of
well i assume comes with the territory
well i wanted to expose what i'd done
and write the book
but i
i took the money uh and i have to say in
my own defense i didn't uh go out and
buy a fence bet but you could take the
money i did take the money i didn't buy
a ferrari
uh it's a good car she looked into her i
know a couple guys that have them yeah
yeah i probably should have
no the way you said that i'm probably
never going to drive that ferrari
there was helicopters all around the
house last night and jen was worried
maybe they were chasing after john i
don't know
i know he's around yeah so i actually
took the money and went back to the
amazon where i'd been a peace corps
volunteer and had such a huge impression
on my life and i'd been reading how the
amazon's being destroyed you know so i
go back to the amazon and tell the
indigenous people there the schwa the
outro people i'd lived with i want to
come and help you save your forests
and uh this started me off on a whole
new career they said well if you want to
change save the forest then don't come
here and try to change us it's your oil
companies your your lumber companies
your mining companies it's your dream
in the north it's your dream of big
buildings and
and and ferraris and and other such
things that are
destroying these forests so change the
dream of your people so i came back and
formed a nonprofit called dream change
and then pachamama alliance i began
writing books about this so
you know i i
500 dollars to silence you was kind of
the model yeah is that what it was don't
say anything we'll give you a half a mil
don't don't write that book they're
they're okay with me writing books on
shamanism and indigenous cultures they
encourage that just not on not on what
i'd done
and then my contract was over by 9 11.
i'm in the amazon with a group of people
that i'm taking in to work with the to
save the forest
9 11 happens
i fly up to new york i go and stand and
look down at that pit
and i knew i had to write this book and
i'm not saying there's a connection
between what i did in 9 11 but it just
struck me that i had to write this book
and this time i decided that i wouldn't
contact other economic hitmen and
jackals as i'd been doing before so the
word had gotten now that's why i get the
threats this time i decided i'd write
the whole book completely in secret as a
confession not as an expose but as a
confession and i figured once i got it
in the hands of publishers it would be
my insurance policy
so i went ahead and did that and thought
it was my insurance policy and then
until i got poisoned and
then
then that put a different what year was
this you said you got a half a million
yeah that's uh equivalent of 1.7 million
dollars today
which is not bad money that you got in
1980.
let me ask you when you work for chass
team maine
chas d main was a company that you were
chief economist for
is that like the equivalent of a you
know booz allen hamilton type of thing
today or who would you compare it to
i don't know that there's anybody to
compare it to we were very low profile
we were always told don't talk to the
press don't let anybody know what you're
doing we're pretty powerful company but
really pro low profile
we did a lot of engineering work as well
as the economic work is it still around
or no no it was it was bought out by
parsons and everything was brought up by
somebody else and the name
disappeared basically everything
disappeared so if you were to if you
were to if you were to say
the the chastity main company of 1970s
today would be xyz who would that be
it was a pr it was a partnership i
became a partner
uh
i i don't know i really don't know but
it's a consulting firm
how would you describe it it was a
consulting firm but it's kind of like
almost all of our work was either for
the world bank or the u.s treasury
department state department uh we did we
did a lot of work for those kinds of
organizations so i hadn't watched
goodfellas for a while the other day on
the flight back from vegas i watched
goodfellas
and you know his girls like so you know
why why does everybody know you why does
everybody respect you and what do you do
he says i do construction
okay nice obviously but you know when
when you guys were asked you know hey
what is it that you do did you say i'm a
consultant what did you say you did yeah
we're we're a consulting firm
consulting like the most vague
some of those companies today the booz
allen hamilton and others that snowden
used to work for and others used to work
for some of these companies are also
consulting companies right and they work
directly with a lot of these
major government organizations nsa et
cetera et cetera so it works it's yeah
well yeah so it answered your question i
mean general electric i've talked to
people at general electric and other
companies that have these ties and so
it's usually in individuals it's so a
lot of people in charleston maine have
no idea in fact after i wrote the book i
got i got emails or letters or whatever
it was in those days and calls from
people said god i always wondered what
the heck was going on and now now i
understand but the so a lot of people
totally in the dark about what's going
on there's just a few that that would be
actually doing that kind of work can i
ask you a quick question just about your
demeanor
when i don't feel no disrespect i see
you and i'm thinking this guy chill's
hippie out kind of dude you know he's
wearing like a jaguar t-shirt
are you the same person you were in the
70s meaning were you a lot more stern
and and straightforward and
because you seem like a pretty chill guy
have you changed significantly or has
this always been you kind of casual and
it's that was perfect for the role
i'm a lot happier now and i think so i
think i have changed a lot yeah i was
pretty uptight i i always worry of
course i wore ties suiting suit and tie
all the time basically except maybe when
i was in some really hot climate where
nobody else was wearing them i wanted to
fit in but yeah and and i had i had up
to 50 people working for me and i was
pretty pretty strict with them you know
i always tried to come across as as
personable because that was part of my
job i really i i say this not as a joke
but my job was to be a con artist it was
to con countries into accepting these
deals and to back them up with very
fancy econometric reports and all kinds
of statistics
and i had guys that would do that you
know just like you you you get guys over
here that can tell you how what put 500
000 in 1980 is worth today
yeah that's our that's our con man
station over there tyler but did you
know you were a con man
meaning like i'm obsessed with the movie
catch me if you can leonardo dicaprio
what an amazing movie right yeah
but he knew what he was doing he was
making moves he was doing things he was
printing out did the whole thing he was
cashing checks forging
did you know that you were a con men or
you were just kind of like no this is my
job and i'm gonna sell it and be a good
company man well i knew that when i was
supposed to what i was in the beginning
i thought what i was doing was the right
thing i was convincing these countries
to take these large loans that would
increase their gdp got it and i'd been
to business school everything revolves
around gdp you know if you can increase
gdp you've helped the country that was
what we were taught
so i believe that for a long time yes i
was trying to talk presidents into doing
this but i thought i was talking them
and then doing what was best for their
people
and
over time so i only did that job for 10
years but in part but i'd say around the
beginning of year five or so i began to
see that maybe the things aren't quite
like they seem partly because i'd been
in the peace corps i spoke spanish and
at a large degree because of tori hosts
and a few other people i think i write
in the book about i was started to date
very seriously a colombian woman in
colombia i had an office in bogota and
one in barranquilla two offices in
colombia
and
her
she had a brother who'd
who was part of farc
you know the the you know the what do
you call it
colombian gorillas and gorillas yeah
and uh she uh you know she was she was
also putting a big buzz in my ear about
well you gotta understand what america
is really doing here
and so i began to see this but once i
began to understand the truth behind
what i was doing i didn't want to
believe it and i think a lot of people
are in this position today in all ways
that we you know i was making a lot of
money i was flying first class around
the world meeting with presidents
hanging out with
you know beautiful women and all kinds
of i was living my dream the american
dream i thought so i really didn't i i
wanted to buy into the sales job that i
was getting and and a couple of times i
started i tried to quit i went and
talked to my boss and said i think i'm
gonna i think i'm gonna quit uh although
take a year or two off or do whatever
you know i tried to be diplomatic about
it they would send me to personnel which
now is human relations you know and
that's human resources human resources
and we got a great hr guy here shout out
to robert
and what happened with that conversation
well well you know he'd sit there and
stare at me and say how could you
possibly leave you're the best job in
the world if you don't like what's going
on exactly you've changed it you're
chief economist you're you're head of
this department and you know stay here
and work from the inside you know the
same old line was he selling you yes oh
absolutely i want to transition into
some current events that's just what i
like to do so
you know
one of the videos i watched of you there
was a quote of john adams and it said
there are two ways to conquer
and enslave a nation one is by the sword
and the other is by debt
okay which is part of your formula on
what you guys did right it was a lot of
debt and you're forcing them to do
whatever you want them to do right okay
there's this country
that is creating a lot of momentum i
don't know if you've heard them it's
called china
and china
u.s owes to china
one trillion
i think it's one trillion fifty billion
dollars is what we owe china okay 1.05
trillion in debt to china
so if this quote is right there are two
ways to conquer and enslave a nation
one is by the sword the others by the
debt by debt
is america enslaved to china
this is a really important question pat
and it's the book i'm writing now comes
out in october it's called again new
confessions of an economic hitman
edition three china's economic hitman
and i've been spending the last three or
four years working on this book china
owns the world now pretty much
and they do it under the guise of the
new silk road which is very appealing to
countries in africa and latin america
and the middle east and all over that
we'll become part of an
international trading network the united
we our economic hit men were never smart
enough to come up with that kind of a
scenario they get a great message
and yes
i think it
the united states and china are
incredibly interwoven
and china's winning this battle if you
want to call it a battle
but at the same time the united states
is also gaining a lot so our investors
have over 100 billion dollars invested
in china
you know where would microsoft be
without china where would apple be where
would where would any of these high-tech
companies be without china and its
technology
a third of all the international
students in the united states today are
chinese they're here learning incredibly
from us they're learning all about us
we're not doing the same thing we're
criticizing china but we're not really
sending many people over to really try
to understand what's going on in china
they don't let you oh yeah they do no
they don't you can go and study in china
let me ask you let me ask you a question
when it comes down to
media we're open we tell the world about
our problems china doesn't tell the
world about their problems
they're
they're very much of a
secrecy where we can't learn about them
that's that that's that's a
misconception pat i hate to say but i i
taught in a business school in shanghai
an nba school it's
constantly ranked as one of the top ten
in the world along with harvard and
stanford and so on
the chinese students there know
everything about what's going on in the
world
many of them studied here or in or in
europe i don't think you got what i said
i said we don't know about what china is
doing because china doesn't want the
world to know what they're doing well we
can go there and learn they don't have
open media they don't have a free press
well they don't there's no social media
in china no just they don't have free
press well you say one bad thing about
the g
your jack ma you disappear for five
months everyone scared shitless their
biggest influencer on their biggest
platform that's a tick tock type of a
model
she had like 50 million followers she
disappeared just because she said one
bad thing and supported the people in
yeah that that's true within china but
outside of china there's a lot of
information that's available
what is the information that you think
is not available what do you mean what
is the information that's not available
china says the unemployment is two
percent do you believe that
do you believe their unemployment is two
percent i do
you believe china
i believe five billion people living
there slave trade you're talking about
people working in
you know
yeah the we you're saying their
unemployment is only two percent come on
john i mean you're counting me right now
if that's what you want me to believe i
don't know whether two percent but it's
low it's very low it's it's it's low i
mean they're putting people to work
tremendously they've brought
close to 800 million people out of
poverty in the last
30 years that's more than the whole rest
of the world combined which is true
for them and they've had part of that
hit on the back of america 10
average annual
growth in their economy would it never
happen without nixon and us though
well yeah that's true
i don't know that of course the world
knows that well nixon went there you
mean nixon is the reason why the trade
is in love with china so
it happened on the backs of america
well that's well you can say that but
you can also say that america has
tremendously profited off china because
as i said our high-tech industries
wouldn't be here without without chinese
goods i don't know i think that's a
strategically a flawed uh
that's a flawed strategy u.s took which
i would agree with that they rely too
much on one country and now they're
paying a price for it yeah so so who's
so what i'm trying to say is there's a
tremendous interrelationship between
these two countries right now i don't
think we can survive without china right
now and i don't think so china can
survive without us they need our market
and the two countries have an incredible
exchange of information and knowledge
all of our high-tech companies like
apple and
have
offices have facilities in china their
high-tech companies have facilities here
there's a huge interchange in that and i
think what we need to do
instead of just always looking at china
as the bad guy and yeah china's made a
lot of mistakes they've done a lot of
horrible things yes the uyghurs and and
what's going on in the south china sea
what's going on in taiwan and hong kong
i'm not apologizing for china what i am
saying is in this world today these
countries are very interdependent this
is not like the soviet union in the
united states we were never
interdependent we did not rely on the
soviet union for technology or anything
else soviet union never offered the
world anything the world really wanted
the soviet union was powerful because it
had nuclear weapons that's it that's
eighth of china's economy by the way
right not even that's russia today the
so yeah the soviet union but you know i
knew a lot of students in latin america
who were
and they would go to school in russia
but they didn't consider russia to be
marxist they considered russia to be
stalinist and they did not want want
ecuador or peru or argentina to have any
government like the soviet union they
did not want to have the economy of the
soviet union they do want the economy
that china has they want to see the kind
of growth that china has demonstrated to
the world that it can do
from 1973 until now china's had
incredible economic growth you know
what's happened in the united states
we've gone from 60 of the population
being in the middle class to 50
we have not had an increase in average
wage when you account for inflation
since 1973 why do you think that is
terrible economic approach in our
country terrible what it's uh it's our
economic system in this country i don't
think it's economical what do you think
it is you think it's economical
you talked about your three guys that
are the richest people that have half
the money right that you talk about as
well okay how do you think they got them
how do you think they got well you you
can't generalize it i mean there's many
different okay how do they do it just
give me your idea how do you think they
got that how do you become that wealthy
in america if i knew i'd probably be one
of them but i don't know what i'm saying
you probably know because you're up
there you tell me
it's not asking you because you i don't
know i don't know how they get there but
but what i do know but what i do know
pat is that they're not being taxed for
it and they're using in their companies
are using infrastructure they're they're
using all of them stop john that's not
that argument you're going to lose
to who's not being taxed for it do you
know who's paid the most taxes
in the history of america an individual
you know who's paid the most taxes ever
in the history of america no who
i said
you know what he paid this year no 11
billion and what percentage of that was
uh versus his income what was his tax
what was his number it's not about his
taxes he didn't take incomes if he takes
income he pays taxes on it's not on
capital gains yeah so that's capital
gains but the point is
to make to pay that much taxes
that's more than every single us
president in the history of america
combined in their lifetime
yeah big that presidents don't make much
money
okay so the american president
go take every congressman every senator
every president every governor combine
all of their taxes in their lifetime
this guy paid more in one year and guys
like you
and guys like others in in in politics
bashed this guy you know how much he
gave to charity yesterday how much do
you think you have to charity yesterday
charity i don't really 6 billion
so what's what's the big whoopee well
what the point six billion i mean what's
it how much is it taken out of this
system no no but the point is the
government who says give us more taxes
and we do
and we give them more taxes
we see nothing
and there's zero accountability
the difference is an elon musk is
publicly scrutinized constantly
because there is a form of
accountability in the free market
private free
free enterprise there is zero
accountability with the government if i
go to tsa for customer service they
treat me like
if i go to clear they treat me royally
clear is a free market company tsa is a
government organization they flat out
disrespect you at tsa they don't have
clear
so the american people are sitting there
saying johnny we'll give more money to
the government just show us what the
hell you're doing with it because you
haven't proven yourself every time you
tell us give us more money erase taxes
raise taxes raise taxes we don't see any
results so what do you want to do at
this point so pat tell me then why has
there been no real
increase in wages in the real average
wage in this country since 1973 why is
the middle class gone from 60 of the
population to 50
why did all the the the the the 200 or
400 and however many billionaires we've
got now what is it uh
it's uh
747 and 42 i think something like that
billionaires made uh i can't remember
the numbers now but seventy percent more
than they had during the pandemic why
and uh
you want me to give you the answer yeah
i'll give you the answer i'll give you
the answer you're ready yeah okay
ever wonder why
politicians
never spend any of their time
coming out with programs to educate low
and middle income families on how to get
out of debt
ever wonder why politicians don't want
to low on middle-income families to
become wealthy and make money do you
ever wonder
maybe these guys don't want you to be
an upper class maybe they want to keep
you at low income maybe they want to
keep you at middle income why
because if they do every two to four
years when they need your vote they're
gonna get your vote when's the last time
you saw a governor a senator a
congressman emphasize education to
adults on how money works let me go to
another step with you here so i totally
agree with you instantly but i'll go to
another part i'll go to another but
you're not really hitting on the point
i'm going to get to the next point here
because your point was that 70 of their
net worth increased in the last 24
months no problem let's talk about that
how much money do we print the last 24
months what's the dollar amount no idea
over 5 trillion over 5 trillion more
than 40 percent of all the money in
history of america has been printed in
the last 24 months okay
now they take that money and they send
what they call it all these money they
send to police stimulus checks to people
the people that are getting the money
with stimulus checks what do you think
they're doing with their money well for
one thing it brought a lot of kids out
of poverty no they didn't yes they did
it
then the statistics would have gone up
but what do you think they do with that
money what do you think they do with
that money you tell me
well you tell me what they do with that
money
if i'm accustomed to spending money and
i'm spending the money buying stuff
i buy more stuff
and when you buy more stuff who's
running those companies that sell more
stuff the people at the top so the money
always flows to the top so essentially
the politicians that you want to
increase the taxes for
they're the reason why billionaires
increased their net worth 70 the last
two years well there's a couple
different things going on it's not a
blanket statement so
and this is what i want to get to the
heart about it because
the facts support that yes people have
spent a lot more money but they've also
more people have gotten out of debt this
is what happens when you print five
trillion dollars there's options people
have saved a lot more people have
um because with unemployment and
stimulus checks they've had a lot more
than their bank accounts they've paid
off debt i think this is the first time
in
decades that
um debt basically personal debt
decreased
uh since the pandemic so it's not just a
blanket statement i'm sorry i'm sorry
adam you can't say something like that
no no you can't say something like that
okay so go to where you just went i'm
just saying that there's not everyone
spent all their money some people saved
some people got out of debt but this is
what happens
let's talk about that guys like you
realize if i give you if i have a
hundred dollars right now i give it to
you
did that hundred dollars disappear
no at the end of the day the money
flowed to the top but let me let me go a
little bit further if i give you a
hundred dollars
did that money disappear no no the money
just transferred to who to you if you
give that hundred dollars to him did the
money disappear no it just went to him
if the money goes from him to him did
that money disappear that hundred
dollars still out there right it's just
not in my hand not on your hand not in
his hand it's now in his hands right
okay fine
that five trillion dollars that we put
in the economy where does that five
trillion dollars go to
so oh my god i paid so many people's
credit card then in college debt really
where did that five trillion go to
pet patent but where did that fight it's
gone everywhere it's gone all of it
circulated all over the economy a lot of
it a lot of it a lot of it a lot of it
went to the stock market and that goes
to basically where elon musk it's it's
bigger than that guys it's bigger than
that this guy is sitting here just gave
this a strategy on how to ruin a nation
who gives a where that five
trillion dollars went to here's what a
five trillion dollars a hundred percent
to our debt to our debt yeah
that five trillion dollars is debt like
what's on one side of the table do you
realize who's the speaker today our
guest today is john perkins economic
hitman where the business philosophy is
what
we can kill him with the sword or debt
and we're like oh but we paid off
college op we paid off credit card
oh but we bought more bitcoin oh but we
bought more nfts oppa we no the
country you love is officially enslaved
to others and what do we have to do with
this money they have to get that money
from somewhere so that we print some
more money oh let's help the poor even
more
this is not the strategy
i'd love nothing more this is a 99 cent
store guy i'm a guy my parents got a
divorce i didn't have any money when we
grew up i'm a guy that went to the
military was going to do military for 40
years if a guy didn't sit there and say
hey you need to kind of figure out how
money works where the hell am i today
i'm just another guy that's sitting
there saying can you please send us more
stimulus checks this is not the right
strategy
we want the same mission to help
middle-income
median income to go higher but the way
to do it isn't to send more money to
people that is not the strategy because
that keeps hurting
that keeps validating your business
model when you went and sat down with
people like you know the guatemala guy
jacopo guzman when you sat down with
ecuador aguilera jaime aguilera when you
went to sat down with panama omar
toriyos when you went and sat down with
you know venezuela when you all this
stuff it just validates the formula
works also what are you saying that it's
good to have a country where three
individuals have as much wealth as half
the populations i'd call that an
oligarchy what would you call it i'd
really like to know what did you say
is that a democracy do you like sports
some what do you what sport do you like
soccer soccer mm-hmm okay you like
hockey who's your favorite hockey player
i haven't been following this year
actually who's the greatest hockey
player of all time gretzky is it fair
that he scored more assists and goals
than anybody else by a mile
that's a shame
john
i'm appalled
that we allow somebody
to beat number two by so much with goals
and assists he should have never
beat the greatest hockey player prior to
him by so much that is embarrassing we
should limit how much he should have
beat second place because
we should give more minutes to the other
guy because god forbid wayne gretzky why
are you getting so many minutes we
shouldn't let him play so much we
shouldn't have these success stories
let's keep people less let's only beat
the record by one goal not not not 600
goals so you're saying you're saying
that the american economy is a sports
game
yes it is
you're playing again capitalism is a
game so socialism the difference it's
the capitalism and the difference is
capitalism you control the game
based on what you said do
think what the united states has today
is capitalism
with a touch of social uh with a touch
of social programs
what we have is predatory capitalism or
oligarchic capitalism there's a there's
not true capitalism there is because
true capitalism yeah true capitalism
you know the definition of capitalism is
that the means of production
manufacturing and commerce are not owned
by the government they're owned by
individuals you're going to lose this
argument when you go keep going we'll
see about that go for
because i enjoy our conversation so let
me continue so so in in our form of
capitalism
uh the india they got the government
does not own individual enterprises okay
but the individual enterprise owners own
the government so when you go and you
talk about our politicians and what
they're what they're doing and so forth
that's because they're owned by the
oligarchy that's because they're owned
by the billionaires what's the problem
so who's the problem the system's the
problem the fact that okay the fact the
fact that corporations and the
corporation owners can put so much money
into this is what they call the crony
council
so guess what so guess what so then so
then this goes to one thing so you think
we should have lobbyists
not on the lobbyists
right now we have 300 lobbyists to every
member of congress you think that's a
good thing no you think we should have
lobbyists period
i think
i think you can have middlemen but
there's not not lobbyists that are that
are so totally selfish how many people
do you see senators and congressmen
retirement become lobbyists making six
million a year a lot okay so what do you
think happens there why do we have that
that's part of the bribery that's part
of the corruption
we shouldn't have that i agree okay then
so we have one area that we agree with
we agree that the reason why these
billionaires can get away with that is
because they have lobbyists that they're
paying money and these senators and
congressmen if you got a half a million
dollars to stay quiet in 1980 what the
hell do you think they're getting behind
closed doors
okay if you got a half a million dollar
stake in 1980 what do you think these
senators and congressmen are getting
wallets and here's 800 000
do me a favor can you make sure you hurt
the other small business owner so i can
whoop his ass i've actually heard that
that if congressman can be bought for
ten thousand dollars can come about it
was a hundred thousand can come on
you're cheaper today and come on your
side but if you really want them to push
for you then it's a hundred thousand
i've heard it's a hundred thousand
dollar number but i don't think that's a
good system though i don't either okay
so we're on the same page with that but
it's not the fault of for example if i
so so it's the fault of whoever created
those laws
not the fault of the capitalist if you
allow players to use steroids if you
allow players to use steroids and it's
legal guess what that's the law
if you don't it's not the law you know
the mlb is no longer testing for
steroids what just happened with the
russian skater
she's not allowed to use steroids but
she did and she's and and and she's been
forgiven for it i just i think so i
guess they're still struggling with that
so we tell me how many people are
watching the olympics today
you're telling me are you are you
watching it i think i'm in it
[Laughter]
the only person i know that's watching
it is my dad and he's watching this
curling i'm like dad what the hell are
you watching and they're watching this
curling game that's going on but but the
point but the point i'm trying to make
to you is it ain't the capitalist it's
the lawmaker well but the capitalists
own the lawmaker no because they are for
sale
if they weren't for sale this wouldn't
be the case why are they for say who do
you blame so do you bring blame the
prostitute or the john
the prostitute has a choice not to be a
prostitute there's a lot because john
has a choice not to be john no no but
wait a minute if the prostitute chooses
not to be a prostitute then john doesn't
can't find a process and the prostitute
goes broke because she's got no other
job no she'll find a different way to
make her money
that's on her maybe no no it's not maybe
ah that's not how life works no way
that's not how life works let me explain
to how life works and you know this is
how life works
you tell a kid
listen
if you
don't figure out a way to pay rent you
got to kind of figure out what you're
going to do if you're going to live here
on rent for me you're 22 years old you
got to kind of pay 600 bucks a month no
you don't get a job you're you're out of
luck you gotta go live with your friends
you're a terrible dad fine you're right
i'm a terrible dad you're a terrible
renter you never pay rent what do you
want to do with you go figure life out
that kid leaves
he does some stuff that he wants to
retaliate against that smokes we does a
little coke goes out there does ecstasy
does everything he can to trash his dad
he's gonna eventually get a job
and if he doesn't get a job and ruins
his life the father couldn't have done
anything about that in the first place
that's on the kid the kid has to
eventually figure out a way to survive
so that prostitute will figure out a way
to make money she doesn't have to go
that route
capitalism works it's the laws
that get people to do things that hurt
others because the laws allow that to
happen so let's look at a little bit of
american history i agree that capitalism
works sure but at the end of the
american revolution the continental
congress and what became the congress
were very concerned because the the
revolution was really about the east
india company that was more than the
crown but the crown was very dependent
on the east india company crown of
england and so
they passed a law that said uh no no
company no nobody could get a corporate
license a corporate charter uh unless
they could prove that they're going to
serve a public interest and charters
lasted for only 10 years
at the end of the 10 years you had to go
back and prove that to show demonstrate
that you had proof served a public
interest and then you could maybe get
another charter also in there was you
could no company could buy another
company or sell itself to another
company
those laws were there to protect us
against corporate power because the
the founders were very concerned about
corporate power because of the east
india company those laws continued for a
hundred years almost about 100 years
until john d rockefeller came along and
he wanted to drill for oil in new jersey
in
delaware and he says you know i can't i
can't drill for oil i can't have a 10
years it takes a lot longer to drill for
oil they got to be able to buy out these
other companies they're competing with
me it's the only way we can get oil so
we went to the legislature of new jersey
first and later delaware and he said you
know if you change the law so that i can
have unlimited powers
uh i'll
i'll give a lot of campaign money to you
legislation for that status yeah and and
that has continued
it's grown and grown and grown to the
point where corporations and their
owners have so much power our
politicians now we can argue all you
want about who's who about the
prostitute and the and the john we can
argue about it
who's at fault is it the politicians or
is it the people that are bribing the
politicians basically that are offering
them these incredibly
lucrative positions when they leave or
even while they're there for campaign
financing and then when they leave if
you don't get elected we'll give you a
great job as a lobbyist or if you did
get elected when you want to retire you
can have a great job
who's to blame for that yeah i i i tell
you it's the law creator the person that
creates the law it's it's not the person
that that bribes the law no you don't
have to you don't have to take the bribe
no i did that though in other countries
and i was and i took the bribe myself so
i got to tell you sometimes you don't
feel like you really got a choice well
fine let's just say sometimes you really
don't think you have a choice your story
is an extreme story when somebody comes
and tells you it's your life and you
have an infant child at that time so i
totally get the threat that you are in a
situation like that
let me let me go to a different angle
with you in the story here let's go
completely different area and see what
angle you would take with it okay
today let's talk about today with what's
going on with ukraine and russia okay
on one end
biden's talking about the fact that you
know russia is going to attack ukraine
russia is going to attack ukraine russia
is going to attack ukraine
ukraine prime minister's like stop
saying that you're scaring the hell out
of my people what does it matter with
you on a call to biden okay
so yeah
when i saw that going on the first
person i thought about was you
i'm not kidding with you first person i
thought about was you i'm thinking of
going to ukraine actually okay so then
maybe you're going there to do some
business which
so first person i thought about was you
i said i said i said i wonder how
john reads this story the day-to-day guy
reads the story saying oh my gosh
russia is going to go in there and take
whatever they want from ukraine and it's
going to suck and
but and then you know maybe somebody
that's a little bit more educated that's
complete something else maybe somebody
else that's a little bit more educated
and follows news a little bit more and
knows you know well you know here's
what's really going on over there and
you know maybe somebody that's a little
bit skeptical with uh you know biden
talking about the fact that he had
dealings with ukraine and he's made
money from ukraine and a big guy and all
that other stuff i said i wonder what
how john looks at this because i know
john politically which way you lean i
know which way you're politically but i
also know as much as whatever side i
lean politically left right center
registered independent
i still still sit there and say
huh
would
would trump have contacted russia to
help him with the election what chances
do i think that would happen huh
that's pretty interesting because
everyone's talking about it now
and this adam guy shift made it there is
certain you know no question about it
there's evidence that there was
collusion with russia like oh he
just said it damn
and this and this and that
and then the dossier came out it was set
up by hillary clinton 35 million bucks
and then durham comes back with the
investigation mueller spent 40 million
this guy only needed 3 million
oh
it was all hillary the entire time
she's the mastermind behind it
what a freaking dirty way of doing it so
you do to the other person and you tell
the world that that person is doing what
you're doing to them they're doing it to
you you really are a con man at the
highest level so from your end
give us all potential scenarios of
what's going on with ukraine russia
let's see if you're going to be open
about it
instead of maybe being selective and
just giving us the side that you want to
give us
what do you think's going on there
i just came from nassau in the bahamas
where i was teaching a course nasa was
the pirate capital of the world at one
time pirate republic
but you know the pirates never um they
didn't want to attack other ships
particularly why they had that big flag
with the skeleton crossbones just
scared the out of
the ships they were coming up and and
and most of the ships knew that if they
just gave up
uh they would have to lose
you know whatever the pirates wanted
that was on their ship but nobody would
be killed
it was the flag the flag the fear the
pirates would appear on the deck
semi-naked or maybe naked looking very
fierce and so on
i think russia is doing that on ukraine
i think russia is standing on the edge
of ukraine uh waving that that jolly
roger skull and crossbone flag and it's
trying to negotiate it wants to it does
not want um ukraine to become part of
nato
it's trying desperately to bring people
it's been very successful incidentally
and now you know the the heads of many
countries are talking to putin they
wouldn't have before so in a way they're
getting their way in terms of getting
everybody to talk to them the united
states is getting all upset and involved
in it and certainly biden is wanting to
look very strong it's a it's an election
year and he's he's wanting to look
strong so he's
he's making it sound as though russia is
absolutely going to attack ukraine who
knows but i don't i was
speaking at a at a conference in russia
in 2017
along with putin we were both speaking
at the conference i got to know his
his uh
top economic adviser sergey glasgow very
well he and i flew a cousin stand
together and spoke there
um you know that the sense i got is that
that putin is a very shrewd operator
he's very very clever
and he knows the world pretty well and
so he's trying to get whatever he can
out of this he's using the leverage of
his troops on the border to get talked
with all kinds of people to get
recognized
he loves he loves to be on the front
page he's getting on the front page a
lot will he actually attack ukraine or
not i have no idea
but i do know that i that we are
the united states and many other
countries are feeding into his hands
you don't think there's anything else
going on there that's politics behind
closed doors that we don't know oh
there's lots of stories behind the
stories for sure i mean any potential
like what if what if it could be maybe
this it could be this it could be that
what are some things you would speculate
if somebody hired you to investigate
this
well i think it could be
part part of it is that that putin is
trying very hard to win friends with
china he sees that china is going to
probably control a third of the world's
economy in the next 10 years that's the
way it's headed
russia is a country that's kind of left
out at the moment you've got
china and the united states are center
stage right now they're they're they're
uh
duking it out so to speak
and russia's left on the outside so
putin's struggling very hard to get back
in there
so you think that's the only thing you
think the only thing is the fact that
putin is trying to get back in there
and he's trying to get closer to china
you don't think there's anything else
that's going on that's skeptical from
our end
well you obviously have some idea about
that i actually don't i don't have
anything i'm asking you because you
you're the guy for example if i talk to
a divorce attorney and i'll say hey give
me the 10 reasons why people get a
divorce
a divorce attorney's done hundreds of
divorces gonna be like well
number one at the top is infidelity okay
number two
you know their high school sweetheart so
they did it because she got pregnant
early and he had to make it look good
and said okay number three is because he
used to be broke now he's famous and
he's the number four
the divorce attorney is going to be able
to speculate all these different reasons
right that people get a divorce i'm
asking the economic hitman to say why
would something like this take place let
me go to a different level
i want you to be creative because i know
you're very creative okay your strength
is being very very creative john
if let's just say
um
you took a half a million dollars from
the people that met with yet uh uh uh
you know in one point
1.7 million that's a lot of money right
you didn't buy ferrari by the way good
for you
um should have you should have i
probably would have 30 million today if
you would have bought one but but let's
just say you got a call
from
somebody at the us government
and they said john
forget about the 1.7 million we'll
double that
and they represent a consulting firm
and it's consulting firms we can call it
jbn associates whatever you want to call
it okay
and their specialty is construction okay
and they call you they say hey john
we'll give you 3.4 million dollars
there's a guy
that's a podcaster we cannot stand
we would love anything
to destroy this guy and get him off air
if you pull it off
we'll give you the 1.7 million up front
we'll give you another 1.7 million once
you get them off how would you do it
so if you were offered a number like
that which is kind of cool you can go to
the amazon and buy three alligators you
can go freaking i don't you can do a lot
of with that right
how would you i mean obviously nothing
like this is going on in america today
i'm just saying if there was a podcaster
that's a very big podcaster and it gets
you know more views than
cnn fox msnbc combined per week let's
just say there's a guy like that out
there that's not happening but let's
just say this
how would you destroy this guy's life
if somebody offered you 3.4 million to
get them off air how would you do it
well i'd probably first still curious
want to appear on a show and and and and
make him look you know like he doesn't
really know what he's talking about so
you would go on a show that was that
would be a start good yeah
and
uh you know then i'd probably let the
air out of the tires of this ferrari if
he had one let's assume that this guy
hit a ferrari i guess he doesn't have a
freight he drives a dodge ram
well that i would i i would buy him a
ferrari you could buy me i don't think
but honestly what do you do to this guy
okay because
we're living in a time where i think
your model
is not as effective today as it was 50
years ago absolutely but it is effective
in different ways because today it's not
an economic it could be a character
assassination so how would you
so today what you do is social media so
what do you do
you hire some really good social media
people to go after this guy
and create all kinds of lies about him
based some of them based on
based on on on
truth a little bit of truth here a
little bit of manipulation a little bit
of manipulation of the truth yeah and
and you go after him in whatever way you
can and it would depend on the guy that
can you can you get him to really expose
himself can you get him to get to get
really angry i mean what what everybody
loves him he's loved by all his
followers
maybe you can get him to use one of the
words that we're not supposed to use
anymore
that's one way to do it yeah get him but
what if you find that and then the
opposition comes back and says well
howard stern said this and joe biden
used the word and this person used the
word so then then what's your next move
if that happens what do you do then
what do you do then john i need your
help john
you're the economic hit man i'm trying
to figure this puzzle out and i'm
leaning on you i think i don't want to
have your level of education i know the
guys
you know
but i think ultimately the point that
you're making that is that whatever
john's answers are they are what they
are but these conversations are taking
place no what you're basically saying
adam what i'm
on on the serious note yeah
i am relying on his ability to be
creative
to tell us if somebody were to do
something like that how you go about
doing it that's what i'm trying to get
from john and i don't know john's given
us the answer i think john's playing it
safe right now well no i think john
doesn't know because because i've been
out of this business for a long time i'm
pretty sure
i'm a writer now but i mean no seriously
you know but i do know that today
uh
character assassination is such an
amazing thing and and there's people
that specialize in it i guess if truly
if i were in that position i would hire
one of those people
uh to
you know to do whatever they do
if if if i really wanted to do that but
i think you know what that i think
beyond all that i would really have to
look at
why am i trying to do this
money
you said some people are well you can be
bought yeah about 3.4 million dollars
i'm trying to get somebody to call you
and give you that 3.4 million dollars if
you can do this yeah but maybe i don't
want to maybe the money isn't worth it
to me anymore and and and maybe what's
the point why why why i guess i'd have
to ask why do we want to get this guy
off the air you want to get this guy off
because he he puts people on that he
interviews that
call you out and expose you and the
people in power are sick of it because
all the manipulation about masks and all
this you know hypocrisy where mayor
garcetti says hey
whenever i take pictures without a mask
and i hold my breath i literally peed my
pants when he said that in an interview
and then he's at the super bowl without
a mask on ever and all these celebrities
that say we should put masks on kids the
next day are gonna have to wear masks
but they don't and this guy talks about
it and he's kind of undermining the
white house and that's not cool so we
have to figure out a way to silence this
isn't that part of democracy
but not today because today is all about
censorship and character assassination
it's a business model that's worked very
well the last two decades i don't know
if you've been following it it's a very
effective strategy yes it is an
attentive strategy yeah but i know we
would like to have a democracy where you
and i can talk where you can go do your
own podcast and say pat's full of
and i think patrick is linked to the
show whatever you want to talk about me
great and let people decide and say i
agree with john and i think the jaguar's
real representation of honesty and i
don't i don't like pat what he has to
say but they have to make that decision
right
i'm team tiger you're tim jaguar
slightly different let me ask you a
different question here's a different
question okay this is your world you
can't
tell me you don't know
john
you can't
play the uh i'm not following that story
okay
i just i i just recently heard you
talking about how you never make
promises you never say you can do
something if you don't can't follow
through
i am not i'm going to play your game i'm
going to
i i respect your i respect your
integrity
i agree
completely or that you don't offer
something that you can't deliver you
don't want that this is why i know you
like omar torijos as much as you do i
know you like him as much as you do so
let me read you what just happened this
week i don't know if you're following it
or not
no one knew i'm sure you're not but you
know some stuff's been happening this
week some crazy stuff happens i've been
in about 9 months
and you know and i want you to know that
i was teaching in the bahamas
at a hindu ashram
so you could imagine how much news i was
getting there you can't even you can't
even get a sure you can't even get a cup
of coffee sure you're not following this
is that what they're doing so let me
read the story let me read the story let
me read this story clinton campaign pay
to infiltrate trump tower
white house servers to link trump to
russia okay now who would do such a
thing because she's a very you know
she's always been known as a sweetheart
so
lawyers for the clinton campaign paid a
technology company to infiltrate
servers
belonging to trump tower
and later the white house in order to
establish an interference
and narrative to bring to government
agencies linking donald trump to russia
filing from special counsel
john durham says okay and for the last
three four years this is the durham
connection let me go and for the last
four years everybody's been saying
durham's gonna find nothing durham's
gonna find nothing there's gonna find
nothing well he did right okay durham
also writes that during former clinton
campaign lawyer michael sussman's trial
the government will establish that among
the internet data tech executive one and
his associate exploited
was domain name system dns internet
traffic pertaining to
a particular healthcare provider
trump tower donald trump central park
west apartment building and the
executive office of the president of the
united states so john durham is saying
that hillary clinton essentially
hired a company
to have a link to russia even though he
wasn't doing it to say he is it's a
setup now as a person who's a former
economic hitman like yourself who you've
gone and you've sat down with prime
ministers and you've said if you don't
do this things are not going to be good
for you can you see anybody deceptive
enough in politics that would ever do
such a thing to our former president
donald trump
absolutely not we have a clean system
here in the united states why would we
why would we even consider that anybody
would do something so that is so
dastardly yeah i mean it's just i i
figure you're gonna say that because the
level of nobility in our politicians is
just incredible right semi-saint status
now here's what i did i still want to
get your thoughts on this i want you to
type in durham um
what do you want to put durham
investigation okay and then and then put
durham investigation and that's it
that's all i want you to put take the
rest of it out and then go to news type
in news okay so watch this uh why does
it do that way
uh go back to all go back to all at the
top
all right let's can you make it a little
bit bigger so we can read everyone how
they titled it
so your favorite word cnn uses the same
word they use against you
special counsel durham alleges clinton
campaign lawyer use data
to raise if you can click on that so i
can read the rest of the title
to raise uh
suspicious about suspicions about trump
right now go back and let's read the
next title
the next one is from new york post xdni
radcliff expect more indictments in
durham's
russiagate probe fox news says clinton
campaign paid to infiltrate trump tower
white house service linked to trump the
hill
durham alleges alleges cyber analysis
exploited access to trump white house
new york times court filing started at
fewer in right-wing outlets
but their narrative is off track can you
go to the wall street journal which is
an independent source that you know just
happened uh w as there you go trump
really was spied on okay and people
trust wall street journal because it's
typically in the center that's an
opinion piece though yeah i know it is
an opinion piece i read that as well but
so what what is what is going on i'll
tell you what's going on yeah so so
there's four pillars of the economic
hitman strategy okay i've been writing
about this the chinese are using the
research yeah that's we're getting into
it all right so so the first
is is fear
uh fear of another country fear of
whatever the second is debt
the third is uh debts like the ewtnt
loans yep money pure debt
fear debt
uh
anxiety over insufficiency we don't have
enough we need to tell our oil to the
other companies so we can have better
education so on and so forth and and the
third is divide and conquer
and as time's gone on
these things have changed so during the
early times and this is those those four
pillars have been there for them say
these four again or no there's fear
death anxiety over insufficiency divide
and conquer right okay and those have
been around for a couple of thousand
years that they've been used in one way
or another
and and in the in the past most of
our history was mainly fear and it was
actual invasions and or fear of invasion
it's like fear-mongering yeah like the
old pirate thing you know the the jolly
roger going up but what we're really
getting into these days is the last one
which is divide and conquer
and right now in the united states we're
having this incredible experience of
divide and conquer so the republicans
and democrats will never agree on things
i mean it's just like
it's like it's it's it's it's uh
it's a very incredible tactic that's
that's making america appear to the
world is highly dysfunctional and that's
what's happening on the other hand the
the
let's call it the autocratic whatever
you want to call it governments like
china are looking very good to a lot of
other countries in latin america and
africa and so on because they can
accomplish something
and i think that's that's actually why
why trump was so popular for one of the
reasons because he seemed as though he
was moving on a track where he would
take command he would he would do that
kind of stuff
um
so i think what we're seeing here
is that divide and conquer it's like
hillary's doing this trump's doing that
the republicans are doing this the
democrats are doing that
uh it's a breakdown of a system yeah but
there's a difference
john there's a difference here's the
difference and both of you guys are more
on the same side than where i'm at with
this because i'm very skeptical about
what this is all about here's the
difference
john
not a single outlet
needed any information
to go out there for three years talk
about
trump was linked to russia they needed
no nothing was confirmed
for three and a half years that's what
they convinced america that that's what
it was they had nothing there was no
allegedly it was it is
certainty
it's happening he's with russia he's
team putin he's putin's puppet everybody
said it with certainty america believed
no no you want me to go play the replay
the greatest hits you want me to bring
you the greatest hits well you don't
think that's what was happening i i
don't think i don't think all of america
agreed by any means oh yo of course
america didn't believe because america
doesn't trust mainstream media of course
but what i'm saying to you is 99 of
media that's all they talked about
that's right that's all they taught and
they convinced
the people a lot of them that this was a
real thing going on now here's the thing
trump hadn't done any of this stuff
right okay a lot of this stuff okay
allegedly yeah
yes but you know that so it's a huge
distraction so what are we really
dealing with in the world today we're
dealing with a very dire circumstance
that that this one digress john no
digress i'm not you're digressing i'm
i'm right on point with durham you're
digressing you're going to a completely
different place right now where i'm
where i'm going to
is the idea that the united states is in
is locked in a battle with china our
economic hitman strategy their economic
hitman strategy then hillary's team
china is that what you're saying okay
i'm saying all of this is distracting us
from that that's not the point does that
no no let's stand on the topic i agree
with you i agree with you that china's
winning i don't disagree with you and
and what are we doing we're getting
distracted by by the way we're getting
such a great place we're getting such a
question
i don't i don't agree with you and i'm
not also getting distracted by the mask
thing the vaccination thing there's so
many things that well that's like saying
that we can't um do two things at once
and there's a lot of things that we're
going to be doing at once the china
thing like for me for instance the
bigger distraction i think is ukraine to
china i think we should stop focusing on
i think ukraine is a lot of smoke and
mirrors you brought up that putin has
maybe allied with china i think that's a
european thing the eu nato they need to
take over what's going on ukraine
i don't think the united states needs to
mess with it all what i will say about
this
and i uh very much was guilty of the
trump narrative because for years and
years and years trump trump putin puppet
everything pat
but what they're saying here
is actually
uh a scandal of the highest proportion
if
it's true
if this is true
this is way bigger than watergate for
years and years and years
they were basically on trump
saying that he was putin's puppet and
believe me trump did nothing to help
that with his secret meetings and you
know tru
russia if you're listening and all that
he didn't do anything to help him
but basically if this turns out to be
true and right now it seems like they're
throwing this guy michael sussman under
the bus don't be surprised if he turns
into the next jeffrey epstein wink wink
so but if this is true
and hillary did do this and did
plant what's the use of the word
infiltrate trump tower and did put that
in there and then she tweeted about it a
couple days before the election if this
turns out to be true
this is watergate of the highest
proportion and you know what as much as
it pains for me to say this trump might
have been right
he might have been actually
correct when he said that they were
spying on his comp campaign because one
of the last interviews he did with uh 60
minutes what's the the the the name
she's like come on uh president trump
you know that's not true he's like no it
is barbara stahl i believe is her name
yeah
i'm not a trump fan
and part of the reason i'm not a trump
fan is because i've been spoon fed this
misinformation
about trump
about about russia much like most of
america but if it turns out that that
hillary actually did do this
she's got some explaining to do yeah so
let me ask last point
it's not just me
66 percent of democrats according to
this poll 66 percent of democrats want
hillary investigated over russia gate
yeah so
it's pretty interesting what's happening
out there and last thing if i put into
youtube
youtube because articles are a lot
easier especially with mainstream media
to write put it out there boom it's done
you put it into youtube
it's only fox news that's covered this
story so either fox news is just doing
what they do riling up the base
or they're actually the only news outlet
that is actually covering this so am i
making sense here yeah but let me ask
you both so what is the significance of
this in the in the long run what where
uh
what what what's what's the
potential outcome i'm sorry john what's
the potential are you kidding me so let
me ask you a question let me ask you a
question
do you think the billionaires who are
illegally using crony capitalism methods
to hurt people should they be held
accountable wait we this is a diversion
from the question i'm about to get to
your answer though do you think they
should be able because that bothers you
a lot what these billionaires are doing
you bother with the three people that
have fifty percent of wealth which what
you're saying more than the bottom fifty
percent of wealth right that bothers you
yes okay
the same way that bothers you this is
the ultimate
ultimate manipulator because you're
you're saying who cares if something
like this i know i'm about
accountability i did not say who cares i
say where is
what is the logical outcome of this of
this if she is doing that she needs to
be held accountable and go to jail truth
accountability right and that's what she
did because whoever
the next person is the same thing the
same thing if trump did do it yeah you
can truth accountability and penalty if
he did true collude with russia that's
exactly what had been accountable to him
true but the same thing should be for
clinton right if this turns out to be
her totally agree truth accountability
and what's the penalty and we're on the
same thing with lobbyists crony
capitalism taking payments all that yeah
yeah no accountability is the key that's
the main thing because totally once
again you know how people say
transparency you know how people say
stuff like i don't trust my vote means
nothing my vote is
if there's no accountability here people
are like my vote means nothing no i
totally agree with you i mean both of
these yeah that's that's why i asked so
what is the final outcome of this
can we get at the truth and if we can
get at the truth
will the system
punish whoever's whoever i don't think
it will i i that's the problem that's
part of that i don't think it will
that's part of the problem
and as you said as adam says if it's if
trump's the problem he should be held
accountable if hillary's a problem she
should be held accountable but will they
be held accountable even if we do
discover which one
the the reality is and this is what pat
always says that what 12 percent
controls america yeah
so you know there's 42 percent they're
going to vote republican regardless
there's 44 percent they're going to vote
democrat regardless there's a couple
percentage they're going to vote for
ralph nader and the green party and joe
jorgensen or the libertarian whatever
but there's 10 to 12 percent usually in
the midwest rust belt they're going to
see this and say
i don't know
it turns out i was lied to and that's
you know why i think um
yeah that republicans are going to
steamroll
uh in the midterms so we'll see
um but
i think
regardless if they do steal like what's
the outcome we're talking about outcomes
here
if mid if the republicans do
basically trample democrats in the um
midterms which i think a lot of people
expect them to do i mean that's just
politics yeah it almost always happens
exactly and
now republicans will control congress
we're going to be hearing a lot more
about this yeah so
yeah and the question is how do we
really get at the truth and you know
it's not an easy one to answer these
days it's and i'm not sure that i have a
husband but i think in a way it's it's
tougher than ever you know i want to
write i want to i think
i think we're getting close to the end
here so i want to raise a subject that
i'd like to have you deal with at some
point
and that is that um
if there was a huge ufo hovering over us
aliens getting ready to attack us
what would china russia the united
states india brazil what would we do
this is the movie independence day i
believe is what you're describing
exactly i don't know whether it's it but
but what would we do would we come
together do you think to protect us yeah
sure that's what they did in
independence yeah
and i would like to say that's an old
movie though isn't it yeah but it's
exactly what you're saying is that yeah
so i was so if we had a common enemy
yeah right so i would like to suggest
right now
that the way we human beings are looking
at the world has alienated us from the
world we are the aliens we've said that
we are apart from
not a part of
nature we are supreme over it's human
supremacy
over nature and as a result there's huge
problems that are sweeping the planet
today
so my suggestion what i'm writing it
where i'm trying to go with this book is
that there's an economic hitman system
that the united states has perpetuated
and now china's doing it it has learned
from our mistakes and our successes and
they're out doing us in it
the hope i think for the world is that
if we can all kind of define ourselves
as as the aliens that we've g and it's
not humans it's our perception of what
it means to be successful humans it's
this idea that yeah you got to throw one
more pass make one more touchdown like
one more billion there's all there's so
much that goes into this but it but what
it's doing is it's threatening
you your new your newly born child's
life you know what kind of a world can
we expect we've got we've got to work
together so we can disagree i think the
chinese and the russians and the indians
we can disagree on so many things but we
let's agree that we're going to come
together to fight the aliens totally get
it the problem here with that example
is the alien
is on the inside
and when the aliens on the inside you
have a show the calls coming from
the house the problem is that we need to
we need to hold people accountable for
us to have a little bit more trust in
the fact that we can unify there's i
think accountability leads to increase
of trust by the way
uh
as much as you and i banter every time
we're together you have no idea how much
i look forward to the next time we're
together i'm being serious with you i
enjoyed every single freaking time we
talked every time we do this i enjoyed
are you go in town or you're leaving uh
today
leaving tomorrow you leaving tomorrow
yeah are you okay if i treat you to the
really good restaurant tonight and you
can go with whoever you're going i got
your bill is that okay with you sure
okay so afterwards i'm gonna tell you
about where i want you to go you're
gonna enjoy yourself when you go there
and i want to say one thing pat and i
was thinking for some of your staff
outside there i love the way you do
things i love your show because i i i
think you are
one of the few people that really is
trying to get at the truth and you come
at it from sometimes an angle that i
don't particularly like
but i like the fact that that's what
you're doing and i i i admire that i
appreciate that that means a lot coming
from you believe it or not i appreciate
it i thank you for that that compliment
and we're trying to stay on your good
side we don't need any
hitman
i will receive it so guys a couple
things number one his latest book
touching jaguar put the link below for
them to go get it uh if you end up
buying touch and jaguar don't do it
without buying
the new confessions of economic hitman
you have to read that book if you've not
read it i know it's an older book that
did well many many years ago you just
got to know what this business model is
so order touching jaguar and order the
new convention confessions of economic
hit man with that being said john thank
you so much for coming out folks we're
doing it again next thursday
i uh this thursday i think this thursday
is jason miller who was part of who he
was part of trump's camp part of trump's
administration and the founder and ceo
of getter of getter which is the one
that uh joe rogan talked about and one
day they got 500 000 new followers okay
for those of you guys that are following
by tim in the direction that we're going
one of the new shows that we just
launched
or today which i'm very very excited
about it's called perfiles perfilas
profiles perfilas we go to small
business owners who are from colombia
who are from cuba who are from argentina
who are from many different places
spanish specifically and they're sharing
their testimony of how they got here
it's a very i had my i had melva watch
this with my dad melva started crying
she was watching one it's such an
emotional episode if you watch this and
we're releasing the first one today
small business these are not
billionaires these are not millionaires
these are small business owners that are
trying to feed their families i want you
to watch this 30-second preview we'll be
launching to today on valuetainment
spanish go ahead tyler
[Music]
you will find the first episode today
being launched right now on
valuetainment espanol tyler put the link
to the channel where people can go find
it as well and we'll be doing these
regularly and if you know anybody that's
a small business owner hispanic south
florida that would like to be considered
for the next paraphilus send us a
message at info valuetainment.com we'd
love to have a conversation with them
and see if they can make it on the
peripheral
program here john thank you folks we
will see you guys on thursday with jason
miller take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you